there's somebody right here obviously
doesn't know what's going on here's a
robe on which is cific this is a fashion
related but let's ignore the poor
quality on its video uh-huh this is from
the 80s hey what's up Brendon was up
Theo Brandon from Maryland gang a couple
weeks ago on the episode I heard you
guys was he rocking hating on Chappelle
a little bit about his uh that Malibu
piece of apparel he had on there okay so
here's my question to Bay Club for you
that Hawaiian shirt hitter or that
flannel what's the superior piece of
clothing gang gang on the situation
daddy did you look like real [ __ ]
wearing that [ __ ] tropical hitter you
know you don't wear it right I don't
know I think it looks good on you man
that's a dark rum commercial memory
target dark Malibu rum yeah yeah oh the
Malibu rum fish is hilarious fire as
their fire dude I was so non-alcoholic
malibu room because I don't drink you
know and half of Malibu was in a fire
anyway so that [ __ ] actually really
worked yeah um
there you go right there she's no Lacey
dark rum I do not have to say it make
you do a backflip two sips it has to pay
Lacey dark her two sips you'll be doing
cartwheels yeah it'll make you uh do a
triple axel right out of your community
college it make you flip right in a
four-year college I didn't go to yeah
those ripped eyes won't stand a chance
well yeah your knuckle deep you should
bring it to Phoenix no come on
crazy and we album sales go to the roof
you know many people reached out to me
asked where my girlfriend got that [ __ ]
Wow she did what she say Staples Center
[Laughter]
do they have closed their Lakers [ __ ]
in nighttime Hill oh yeah bro
oh yeah that's that James a border flea
market was your girl pisser I know you
think he's girl watches this show yeah I
hope she does not so what'd you guys
pick I like a nice flannel you do
yeah a nice blue nice flat looks pretty
dumped with right jeans right kicks he
looks pretty fly can never go wrong with
flannel yeah that's a lady me Andy look
at the way feels dress for God's sakes
and look at me what do you think that oh
I love flannels especially flannels on a
guy gives me that like lumberjack vibe I
mean you could get like that Jack they
call it that LJ yeah oh dude yeah you
know Nixon it's gonna pick flannels I
can't see Nick and a Hawaiian shirt yeah
you don't drop out of college become a
professional gambler and wear Hawaiian
shirts going online yeah you can't make
any money real money in person five
tables at a time baby really mmm Wow it
was honest and that's like when I
started really listening a podcast and
[ __ ] so all things happen for a reason
yeah you're the same thing just daddy
funded him you know I'm Sam and what
about you chin how did you end up in the
podcast world um it's a boring story
though not really it's kind of a dope
story well I was doing I was
producer in a voiceover director for a
Spanish dubbed Korean television show
there's a kpop show so I actually
directed people voiceover Directorate
people in Spanish oh wow yeah a little
bit nice directing people directing hold
networks directing people no they're
actually they're actually Spanish
speakers but they're dubbing / Korean
television show kpop show did they have
to speak English also and you told that
you you translated the korean to english
and just told them in english no so we
had a translator do the entire sheet and
then i would just direct them how to say
it just like to voice act it was just
voice acting I said well then I did that
and I rented my own studio so I built
the whole studio there - mm-hmm
and I rented that on the weekends my own
with my own money and produced podcast
just to learn it and then Brennan and
finally kid Brendan was on Joe Rogan's
podcast they're looking for a producer
and I just randomly thought I'm gonna
see him at a show
give him a thumb drive with all my
information on it all the shows I did
all his stuff he took it reached that
later
boom what do you do with the thumb drive
I did a set at the Laugh Factory so what
five years ago chin for for four I was
doing set the Laugh Factory I got stage
and chit was like I'm your next producer
or else samurai sword he was a badass
thanks dude
and this has actually haunted me for
years he came in to Corolla because he's
friends with Chris Locke samana who's
Adam Carolla's producer and I worked
there at the time and he came in just
like asking questions how they ran stuff
and he left and I wanted to apply I was
not qualified at the time to like run a
podcast but I literally I go to Chris I
go I hope he doesn't get it
literally felt I live like that was just
bad juju you got a room for people I
feel bad at 195 no match two men do wish
in the darkness on people move in there
brother
I'm glad I got it off my chest all right
look what you have now I do I do
got it out I hope he doesn't get it what
the hell is your problem
you're like everything's my pouch where
do I start
[Music]